first here with reaction our top stories
former senior counsel to president trump
kellyanne conway along with former trump
white house chief of staff reince
priebus kellyanne start with you
now i watched this interview with
zielinski and i watched it very closely
i actually thought for the first time
probably over a decade at least
60 minutes actually did a decent segment
but it was zelinski's strength that made
this segment and his resolve the fact
that he didn't get on a private jet get
asylum in some other country and take
you know cash and precious metals out
with them he's there fighting for his
country the odds are pretty high that he
may not make it through this but he he's
telling the world this is what is going
on here pay attention it's about good
and evil at this point
yes and he's calling out these fancy
title committees at the un and nato for
not helping for really looking the other
way in the face of genocide and tragedy
and you know sean it sounds so fun for
us to
ridicule joe biden and his inability to
lead to speak to inspire to have a plan
to show compassion but guess what
it's worse than that he's back in the
basement he just spent his 116th
day in delaware as president took his
38th trip there
and and can you imagine that he's doing
that while zielinski is is really
fighting for the sovereignty and the
security of his country
and is being walked you know is walking
around with boris johnson from the uk
this is a president in biden who has not
inspired unify the country yet president
zielinski has somehow that's the
president many americans are looking
toward and saying wow there's somebody
who's standing shoulder to shoulder a
peer-to-peer with his own people but
zielinski is also i mean it was quite
bold for him to tell 60 minutes in full
view for the world
that he is hearkening back to to hitler
and the atrocities of world war ii and
that he sees the analogies here so i i
think it's a very strong interview i
wish we had some kind of response about
it from our own president but look at
his poll numbers internationally
domestic i don't know how low joe can go
every time we discuss this i figure he's
hit rock bottom but he's got a bit big
new problem
people draw a direct line between joe's
feckless and reckless policies action
and inaction with their own suffering 65
percent in that cbs poll say that they
don't think that joe biden has done
enough to help with inflation or fuel
prices and 66 percent are blaming him
and the democrats so they're drawing a
direct line between their own pain
and and what's happening look food fuel
formula for babies these are not
luxuries these are everyday consumables
and necessities and people are having a
very hard time meeting basic expenses
you know brian says i look at this and
you think uh
we know that putin didn't do this when
donald trump was president he did it
when joe was vice president obama was
president and i'm looking at boris
johnson i'm thinking why can't that be
the u.s president why didn't putin do
this under donald trump he had four
years to do it it was what 2014 when he
quote annexed crimea and why did he do
with biden in office and do you agree
with me there's no urgency that's needed
here
well i totally agree with you but you
know the other half of the of that
famous quote about peace through
strength is that only weakness only
invites aggression the world's not
afraid
of joe biden but you know i was thinking
about
when you two were talking we all sit on
airplanes every you know every week and
sometimes you sit by republicans
sometimes you sit by democrats i've
never had
any conversation with any democrat
that makes the argument to me that joe
biden is doing a great job as president
i've never had a democrat tell me that
and and i'll tell you why because when
joe biden ran he ran on a specific theme
and the theme was is that joe biden was
the safe choice for america and every
three months joe biden gets up there and
says america is back america is back and
as kellyanne just pointed out
look with spring break time right
gas is up 40 percent
car rentals are up 40 i mean have you
all rented a car lately and paid that
price it's amazing you go shop for a
used car because a lot of new cars you
can't get anymore because there's not
enough chips for those used cars are up
forty percent and so the gas is up
almost double right
yeah
it's what
yeah it's up like 40 i mean the 40 is
the new the new normal
a million people are getting ready to
cross the border over the next six weeks
dhs the biden dhs is saying a million
people are going to cross look the
democrats have had complete party
control the country is spiraling and and
i think republicans now have to have a
really challenge to constantly point out
where were we when we had total control
over washington d.c we had record
unemployment if you were black american
hispanic american white american wages
were up al qaeda was dead
there were no foreign policy disasters
north korea
didn't do a thing for four years so we
have a real
image and picture that we can present
to voters across america they're already
there
he was a safe pick nothing's going well
democrat
now it's up to republicans so to share
the share the difference they know the
difference donald trump was a strong
president yeah he was strong with the
press maybe he tweeted out a thing or
two that really offended people i'm not
so sure it did
but he was a strong decisive engaged
president this guy this is a weak
president and this is what happens to
the world when america doesn't have
strong leadership uh reince good to see
you kellyanne thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else